bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour ce petit cours d'anatomie comparée
aux aujourd'hui on va répondre à la
question à quoi servent les fausses
temporal donc pour ça j'avais m'aider
d'un crâne de chien et d'un crâne de
crocodile alors présentons d'abord ce
que sont les fausses temporal sur le
crâne de crocodile que vous avez ici les
fausses temporal comment le localise et
bien il faut regarder ici d'abord le
l'orifice du nez ici donc les narines
ensuite quand on bouge vers l'arrière on
tombe sur les yeux et à l'arrière des
yeux donc à l'arrière de ces deux trous
qu'on appelle les orbites on à la région
de la tente des tempes et ses tempes et
bien c'est là qu'on va trouver les
fausses temporal et des fausses temporal
vous voyez elles sont ici et là donc là
vous avez les deux fosses temporal
supérieur est ici vous avez une fausse
temporal inférieur et une autre fosse
temporal inférieure juste ici donc ces
fausses vous voyez la leçon elles sont
symétriques deux fosses temporal
supérieur de fausses temporal inférieur
et sur le chien des fausses temporelles
sont un peu plus difficiles à localiser
alors pareil on organise le nez puis on
localise lors d'it et à l'arrière de
l'orbiteur dans la région de la tente
vous allez avoir la région temporale est
en fait la fosse temporal du chien elle
est un peu plus difficile à localiser
parce qu'en fait c'est ce trou là vous
voyez à l'arrière de l'orbiteur qui est
marqué par cette petite pointe ici vous
avez ce trou ici et ça c'est la fausse
temporal du chien comme pour le
crocodile ces fausses temporal ça va
être des insertions essentiellement des
installations musculaire elles ont
d'autres rôles parfois mais le rôle
essentiel c'est vraiment l'insertion
musculaire donc ici vous allez avoir le
muscle temporal qui s'insèrent ici vous
voyez que c'est légèrement rugueux avec
une crête sagittale qui va aider à la
station de ce muscle et se muscle il va
se projeter à l'intérieur de la foule
temporal ici et chez le crocodile alors
chez le crocodile c'est encore plus
intéressant parce qu'en fait chez le
crocodile vous allez avoir cette surface
qui est très très très
très très très ornementé comme cela la
surface du crâne va être ornementé pour
la pour ces petites fosses ici qui
contiennent des récepteurs des
récepteurs qui s'appelle les dom
pression récepteur qui sont des
récepteurs qui capte les variations de
les variations de pression dans l'eau en
fait quand le crocodile est immergée et
dont qui ont une forme de dôme et c'est
pour ça que ça s'appelle les dom
prêcheur receptor donc cette surface a
augmenté elle s'interrompt partout où il
y à un muscle en fait donc d'un seul
coup la surface devient lisse comme si
en fait les muscles à les polir la
surface de l'eau ce donc ça rend la
section en fait ça rend l'identification
de ces insertions musculaire très facile
sur le crocodile donc quand on regarde à
l'intérieur des fossettes hambourg
allait bien on voit assez clairement en
fait que l'insertion que ces surfaces
sont parfaitement lisse et alors là le
crocodile vous voyez si je glisse mais
doit à l'intérieur des fausses temporal
vous voyez ici là vous avez la fosse
temporal inférieur et là vous avez la
fosse temporal supérieur
supérieur ici est inférieur là donc là
on voit très bien en fait que les
fausses temporal elle arrive par le
dessus enfin le must temporal sincère
donc par le dessus et bien se projeter
vers l'intérieur ici en direction de
quoi vert en direction de la mâchoire
voilà la mâchoire qui vient s'articuler
de cette façon ici voyez on l'articulent
correctement et quand on articule en
fait la mâchoire correctement eh bien on
se rend compte là en fait
que on a ici donc les muscles temporaux
qui sont situées là au niveau de ma main
vont venir sa série ici dans ce creux la
de la mâchoire
donc c'est dans ce creux la de la
mâchoire que des muscles la de cette
grosse qualité que vous voyez ici et qui
s'attache pierre et où s'attachent la
cavité où s'attachent les muscles
temporaux c'est ici qu'ils vont aller
s'attacher au niveau de la mâchoire et
vous voyez ça forme une structure qui
est anatomiquement très cohérente sur le
chien maintenant il si vous avez donc la
tâche du muscle temporal sur le dessus
du crâne et ici vous avez donc le muscle
temporal qui va partir dans cette
direction pareil direction la mâchoire
inférieure donc mâchoire inférieure on
voit ici donc on l'articulent
correctement de cette façon et qu'est ce
qu'on voit et bien on voit que le muscle
temporal va démarrer ici glissé dans
cette direction là est pareil ça fait
une surface très cohérente très
anatomiquement cohérente avec ici cette
fausse qui va accueillir le muscle
temporal de cette façon vous voyez là
c'est tout en continuité donc ce muscle
temporal il va permettre de fermer la
bouche essentiellement à fournir de la
puissance pour fermer la bouche pareil
chez le crocodile est par contre vous
aurez remarqué que le crocodile et le
chien ne sont pas du tout des fausses
temporal qui sont de la même taille
voyez si vous comparez les fausses
temporal du crocodile ici donc ça c'est
la fausse temporal inférieur ça c'est la
fausse temporal supérieur inférieur
supérieur et ça c'est la fausse temporal
unique du chien donc le chien est un
synopsis il n'a qu'une seule fausse
temporal le crocodile est un 10 abside
il a deux fosses temporal dioxyde de là
vous voyez qu'en fait la fosse temporal
synappci d' du chien elle est beaucoup
plus grande proportionnellement à la
taille du crâne que les fausses dit
abside du crocodile voix c'est parce que
vous avez en fait deux modes de morsures
de mode pour générer de la puissance au
moment de la morsure pour capturer la
proie qui sont très très différent chez
le chien vous avez une seule et unique
fosse temporal qu'on appelle donc l'info
synappci death est ce juste temporal qui
va générer de la puissance pour fermer
la massonne chez crocodile c'est un peu
différent vous avez donc ces fausses dit
abside ici qui on est tous petits
muscles et en fait c'est tout petits
muscles ils vont pas générer
suffisamment de puissance pour attirer
la mâchoire valour tout seul c'est
essentiellement les muscles qui sont
attachés à ces deux énormes
protubérance ici que vous voyez là qui
s'appelle les ailes tout errigo id cl2
thériault id chez le crocodile ou voyait
qu'elles sont absolument énorme et en
fait elles servent d'attache à un muscle
qui s'appelle le muscle pts et rigaud id
donc il ya des muscles vérino vide un
peu de ce côté là mais c'est surtout à
l'intérieur le muscle le muscle bike
loide
dorsale donc vous avez un must le
terrygate dorsale qui se trouvait à
l'intérieur de cette fausse ici et qui
s'attache sur l'intérieur ici des ailes
du delta lloyd et vous avez des muscles
perrigault id ventraux qui sont attachés
plus de ce côté ci en fait dlt rigolade
vous voyez que ses alter ego et elles
sont très très développée à cause
justement de ses muscles qui sont
absolument gigantesque et quand on
articule
la mâchoire correctement chez un
crocodile comme ceci alors on observe
une belle cohérence anatomique voyez
belle cohérence anatomiques avec du coup
ici des muscles perrigault id qui sont
attachées ici sur cette phase là d'une
processus ce terrible aux ide ils vont
aller ici sur cette face lisse une belle
continuité anatomique entre ici et là
justement c'est bien vissé bien continue
et ici des muscles qui se trouve à
l'intérieur ils vont ressortir par la
voyez ils vont ressortir par là et venir
saint céré ici le long de cet énorme
faux ce que vous voyez là sur la
mâchoire c'est ça qui va tirer la
mâchoire comment ses muscles vont se
contracter ici donc vous avez ce jeu de
muscles cité rigaud indoor salle théo et
ventrale qui vont se contracter comme ça
craque et qui vont attirer la mâchoire
vers le bas comme ça et qu'ils vont
fermer la mâchoire et vous voyez la
puissance de ses muscles et directement
retranscrite sur le crâne par les
immenses ailes terry gou id que vous
pouvez voir ici et c'est ce muscle
théorique qui va donner sa puissance à
la mâchoire du crocodile donc voyez là
on est sur deux directions
évolutif complètement différente chez le
crocodile est celle eux le chien est en
fait ce sont deux directions évolutive
qu'on retrouve dans toute l'évolution
des synapses ide et dans toute
l'évolution des sur oxyde c'est que
généralement chez les soro psylle ce
sont les muscles perrigault et qui vont
assurer la puissance de la mort sur les
fausses dioxyde vont être
proportionnellement plus petit que chez
les synapses id c'est essentiellement
les muscles temporaux qui vont assurer
la puissance de la morsure alors que si
vous regardez en dessous du g 20 les lt
rigaud idy si elles sont toutes petites
elles sont toutes petites et très
fragile donc généralement cassées et
leur fragilité en fait n'a d'égal que la
petite taille des muscles petits rigolos
id des mammifères les mammifères ne
compte pas sur leurs muscles perrigault
id pour fermer leurs mâchoires
maintenant autre chose d'amusant à
propos de ses muscles perrigault id
c'est que comme vous voyez ici vous avez
la bouche est donc là c'est le passage
que va emprunter la nourriture pour
atteindre la gorge qui se trouverait ici
et là vous avez donc les muscles terry
lloyd qui sont en plein dans le passage
ça va poser un problème pour le
crocodile parce qu'il va pas pouvoir
avaler pour pouvoir avaler il va falloir
qu'il ouvre la bouche pour pouvoir
relâcher les muscles terry droid et à
chaque fois en fait qui va ouvrir la
bouche en fait le risque de perdre sa
proie donc il va faire un petit
mouvement de balancier en arrière ce qui
va permettre d'amener la proa vers
l'arrière refermez immédiatement et
ainsi de suite donc les crocodiles
évidemment ne mâche pas parce que coûte
leurs dents sont pointus ils n'ont pas
de mots l'air pour pouvoir mach et non
pas de meules contrairement aux
mammifères donc très souvent qu'est ce
qui va se passer il va se passer qu'un
bout de un bout de viande va se trouver
ici pendant un moment pendant un cycle
en fait où le crocodile va devoir
rebasculer la tête et ré ouvrir la
bouche pour pouvoir faire progresser ses
morceaux de chair jusque dans sa grange
et pendant tout ce moment là bas le
crocodile ne peux pas respirer en tout
cas pas par la bouche puisque évidemment
le morceau de viande est coincé entre
les deux énormes perrigault idée
d'ailleurs ça se vend très bien quand un
crocodile à la gueule ouverte il a tout
petit trou en fait ici
pour le passage de la nourriture alors
comment ils se sont adaptés les
crocodiles hélas
le trou qui permet de respirer se trouve
ici c'est ce qu'on appelle les crânes
interne voiliers et tout ça c'est ce
qu'on appelle un palais secondaire
palais secondaire qui sait pas la
qualité des narines de la cavité buccale
la qualité des narines se trouve de
l'autre côté donc la cavité nasale si
vous voulez se trouve de l'autre côté de
ce mur haut ceux du palais alors qu'ici
on a la cavité buccale et les deux sont
séparés ce qui permet en fait quand un
bout de viande est coincé là ça permet
un crocodile de respirer donc par les
naseaux ici up l'erp rentrer se promène
ici sous le palais secondaires donc ici
il est derrière ce mur derrière le
palais secondaire et va ressortir la
derrière le bout de viande coincé en
fait donc grâce à ce palais secondaire
les crocodiles peuvent respirer quand
les proies des morceaux de croix sont
coincés dans leur gorge l'autre l'autre
effet du palais secondaire notre utilité
du spal et secondaire c'est qui va agir
en fait comme une sorte d' arc boutant
qui va tenir les deux côtés de la
mâchoire ensemble et donc ça va en
finale ça va renforcer la mâchoire et
particulièrement quand les crocodiles
attrape des proies qui se débattent en
fait donc ça va résister au phénomène de
torsion que crée la fois quand elle se
débat parce que les crocodiles ont un
très long museau et un très long museau
ça casse très facilement donc ce palais
secondaire c'est un renfort en fait pour
empêcher qui va empêcher le museau de se
casser et là où ça c'est intéressant en
fait c'est que les mammifères aussi ont
un palais secondaire mais pas du tout
pour les mêmes raisons donc vous voyez
les mammifères ils ont le trou qui
permet de respirer ici donc lunaire
rentrer ici et va se promener nar de
l'autre côté de ce mur ici qu'on appelle
le palais pour ressortir ici directement
vers la gorge entre les deux andy reid
aux ide donc là vous avez finalement la
surface en fait
emprunté par l'air qui est marqué par
sept petites gouttières ici est donc au
niveau de cet espace là en fait de cette
distance y en fait l'air va traverser la
cavité du nez puis ressortir ici
directement dans la gorge et ça à quoi
sert ne pas les secondaires chez les
mammifères alors évidemment il va y
avoir aussi un rôle de résistance à la
torsion mais beaucoup moindres puisque
vous voyez que chez le chien le museau
est beaucoup moins longs ce qui va ce à
quoi il va servir surtout c'est qu'en
fait les mammifères ils ont des meules
ils ont des molaires voilà qu'ils ont
des meules discernable moudre la
nourriture c'est à ça que servent les
meubles les molaires ont mâché la
nourriture est en fait pendant que la
nourriture mhsa elle occupe l'espace de
la bouche et sas espace de la bouche du
coup il ne peut pas servir à respirer
pendant ce temps là alors comment les
mammifères fonds pour mâcher et
respirant en même temps il respire par
le nez
ici vous avez l'espace qui est occupée
par la nourriture en train d'être mâché
et une mère peut continuer à circuler de
l'intérieur à l'extérieur au niveau des
kohan interne qui se trouve là donc le
palais secondaire c'est pas du tout la
même chose chez les crocodiles que chez
les mammifères alors superficiellement
ils se ressemblent mais ils ont évolué
de façon totalement indépendante pour
des rôles complètement différent et ça
ça se voit très bien dans le registre
fossile puisque les mammifères le palais
secondaire des mammifères a évolué au
trias alors que le palet secondaire de
crocodile lui il a évolué au jurassique
et au crétacé donc c'est pas du tout à
la même époque que le palais secondaire
s'est développée dans les deux limiers
et tous les deux avaient des ancêtres
s'empaler secondaire alors maintenant
les petits fun les petites légendes
urbaines a proposé crocodile alors la
première légende urbaine c'est qu'on
peut tuer un crocodile en lui plantant
un stylo entre les deux yeux c'est pas
vrai regardez la sas et les deux yeux
ici c'est du solide vous n'atteindrez
jamais le cerveau avec en plantant un
stylo ici c'est les jambes qui vient du
fait qu'en fait certains reptiles ont
ici un petit trou qui s'appelle le
foramen pinéale pour le troisième oeil
l'homme idéal qui n'existe plus chez les
mammifères donc ne cherchez pas votre
troisième oeil mais en tout cas certains
reptiles ont un trou ici pour l'oeil
pinéale trou qui mène effectivement
directement au cerveau donc si vous
plantiez un stylo de danse saturait
effectivement le reptile en question sur
un varan de komodo
toujours essayé à vos risques et périls
par contre sara crocodile vous n'y
arrivera jamais puisque le foramen
pinéale n'existe pas chez les crocos ni
une autre une autre histoire mais qui
elle est vraie c'est l'histoire que les
crocodiles en fait on une honte une
morsure extrêmement redoutable
extrêmement puissante dû à leur muscle
terry lloyd certes de par contre
l'ouverture de la bouche est tellement
faible qu'on peut tenir leur museau de
cette façon avec une main et finalement
les empêcher à les empêcher d'ouvrir la
bouche alors c'est vrai c'est vrai ce ci
dit je ne recommande pas de le faire
parce que balaie les crocodiles ont une
puissance gigantesque notamment dans les
muscles de la queue et de et de fait il
vous aura décoché un énorme coup de
queue avant même que vous ayez eu le
temps de réfléchir à eddy donc en fait
c'est vachement facile de tenir le
museau de crocodile alors c'est vrai que
l'ouverture de la mouche chez les
crocodiles est relativement faible et
c'est dû à ce petit mécanisme en fait
qu'on voit ici qui est très simple en
fait c'est un levier donc ici si vous
regardez les muscles qui permettent
d'ouvrir la bouche chez les crocodiles
on les voit bien ici voyez c'est tout
lis ici et ça ça colle et ça vient
s'attacher à ce crochet qui se trouve à
l'arrière de la mâchoire et ce crochet
et bien il suffit aux crocodiles au
final de le tirer avec une légère
contraction de ce muscle pour ouvrir la
bouche et vous voyez ça fait un
phénomène de levier donc une légère
contraction du muscle qui pas cela
suffit à ouvrir la bouche et de fait se
muscle non seulement n'est pas très gros
mais en plus ce n'est pas très puissant
parce que justement ce ce levier ici est
très efficace et donc permet aux
crocodiles d'économiser beaucoup
beaucoup d'énergie enfin un petit point
maintenant dessein intelligent donc on
entend souvent dire que la nature est
bien faite et bien sachez que pour ce
qui est de la mécanique de la mâchoire
la nature est une catastrophe la nature
est une véritable catastrophe en termes
de fermeture de mécanique de fermeture
de la mâchoire puisque en fait si vous
regardez bien où est ce qu'on a besoin
de puissance au niveau de la mâchoire on
en a besoin au niveau des dents au
niveau des dents
parce que c'est là justement que l'outil
pour tuer la froid se trouve et où se
trouvent les muscles qui permettent de
fermer la mâchoire normalement sur un
mécanisme bien huilé
il devrait se trouver là où se trouve
justement l'appui là là où on a besoin
de la puissance
devrait se trouver là les muscles et en
fait non il se trouve ici à ce niveau là
donc les muscles qui servent à fournir
de la puissance ici
se trouve là c'est un petit peu comme
avoir une porte voyez les gonds si ça
c'est l'articulation de la mâchoire ici
et on voit bien l'articulation là là et
là donc ça c'est l'articulation de la
mâchoire ce sont les gonds d'une porte
d'un cycle en droit vous avez besoin de
plus de puissance pour fermer la porte
c'est de ce côté ci de la porte est bien
ici la poignée de la porte au lieu de se
trouver là elle se trouve là donc c'est
comme avoir une poignée de porte juste à
côté des gonds savait alors ça empêche
pas de fermer la porte à d'avoir la
poignée de la porte juste à côté des
gonds c'est juste que vous allez avoir
besoin de quatre fois plus d'énergie
pour fermer la porte avec la même
efficacité que si la poignée se trouver
là donc en fait avoir les muscles mastic
ateurs à l'arrière du crâne que ce soit
au niveau des petits rigolos id ou au
niveau des fausses temporal est basse et
c'est la pire idée du monde en fait et
le muscle mastic ateurs devrait se
trouver là en fait est là on aurait
énormément de puissance pour pouvoir
claque permet la bouche bref
c'est c'est intéressant de voir en fait
comment la nature est mal foutu de ce
point de vue là le problème en fait
c'est que de base nous avons évolué nous
animaux terrestres que ce soit crocodile
chien ou humains nous avons évolué à
partir d'un ancêtre qui vivaient dans
l'eau et ses ancêtres qui vivaient dans
l'eau qui était que nous aurions
identifiés comme des poissons
n'avait pas besoin d'une morsure
extrêmement puissante en fait pour
attraper leurs proies
évidemment pourquoi ces carnivores ici
ont besoin de puissance dans le bout de
la mâchoire et c pour attraper les
proies les poissons eux ils n'ont pas
besoin de puissance pour attraper les
proies puisqu'ils vivent dans l'eau donc
de quoi ils ont besoin les poissons
juste besoin d'ouvrir la bouche locaux
qui rentrent dans leur bouche va aspirer
la proa directement et non plus car
fermée donc ils ont besoin d'un tout
petit peu de force pour ouvrir et là
tout petit peu de force ensuite pour
fermer et c'est tout c'est pour ça en
fait ils ont évolué dans la bouche telle
qu'on la connaît aujourd'hui c'est parce
qu'en fait ils n'ont pas besoin de mieux
que ça les poissons mais comme les
animaux terrestres ont évolué à partir
de poissons et bien ce système de gaulle
situé juste à côté des muscles mastic
ateurs ben a eu d'autre choix que de se
développer ainsi puisqu'il n'y avait pas
de muscles en fait ici il ya aucun
muscle au niveau du museau ici que ce
soit chez de crocodile voyait la surface
comment elle est recouverte complètement
ornementé il ya aucun muscle au niveau
du museau qui peut être qui peut évoluer
pour devenir un muscle mastic ateurs
efficace situées loin des gonds de
l'articulation ici donc on a tous évolué
à partir de ce plan de base qui est un
plan de poissons plan de poissons qui du
coup
était très efficace pour ouvrir pour
simplement ouvrir attendre qu'une proie
soit aspirée par l'effet de pompe il
suffit de faire du vide en fait dans la
bouche et l'effet de pompe va aspirer la
proie et pouf on referme le piège on va
tous évolué à partir de ça donc avait à
partir de muscles qui avait pas besoin
d'être particulièrement fort et qui donc
se trouvait à l'arrière du crâne parce
que de toute façon il n'avait pas besoin
d'être particulièrement fort et après
quand on a après la sortie des eaux et
bien là on a eu besoin de muscles
beaucoup plus puissant mais on n'avait
pas ce qu'il fallait on n'était pas
équipée comme il fallait donc on a
développé des muscles mastic ateurs
voyez gigantesque temporal temporaux
pour les synapses ide et bérigaud id
pour les europe side des muscles mastic
ateurs gigantesque pour développer
énormément de puissance pour compenser
le fait qu'ils sont très très mal si tu
es tels des poignées de porte à côté des
gonds certes le crocodile les carnivores
en général sont des mécaniques
absolument
gigantesque impressionnante et semble
nous dire à quel point ces prédateurs
sont bien adaptés à être des tueurs
extrêmement efficace il n'en est rien en
réalité c'est du bricolage tout ça voilà
c'est tout pour moi je vous dis à très
bientôt sur notre chaîne salut